des murs qui ont une âme depuis plus de
20 ans au côte-d'or une association
s'est donné une mission redonner vie au
patrimoine bâti bourguignon les
bénévoles remonte un rassemblement des
murs de clos des murs de soutènement
comme celui ci où des cas botte de
petits cailloux architecturaux qui trace
un chemin sur le sentier du paysage
viticole
en général on ont fait un parement
d'aspe pierre sèche c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas sur la pierre sèche
traditionnel parce qu'on utilise la
chaux mais d'un point de vue esthétique
et d'un point de vue matériaux ça on
reste donc dans une approche qui est
respectueuse qui est cohérente qui
permet de valoriser aussi des savoir
faire traditionnels entre 2015 et 2017
plus de 220 kilomètres de murs ont été
recensés dans l'espace inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
aujourd'hui seuls deux kilomètres ont
fait l'objet de travaux de restauration
grâce à des donateurs privés étrangers
pour la plupart infondées aide a été
levée par l'association des climats de
bourgogne la moitié du montant des
travaux peut être pris en charge dans
une hutte de 25000 euros
ils sont 65 propriétaire en avoir déjà
bénéficié et un nouvel appel à projets
est lancé c'est m
pour répondre à cet appel d'offres il
faut avoir un élément existant ou ayant
existé à restaurer faire appel à des
entreprises qui restaure de manière
traditionnelle donc murs en pierres
sèches ou murs maçonnés à la chaux et il
faut être sur le territoire inscrit au
patrimoine mondial
donc ces dossiers sont examinés par un
comité de sélection pour des travaux qui
peuvent démarrer dès dès le début avril
autre critère de sélection les
constructions doivent être visibles de
la voie publique à ladoix serrigny
pierre cornu a tenté sa chance
je n'avais aucune idée si je serai
sélectionné ou pas bon je me disais
c'est quand même un endroit bien placé
sur cette belle colline de corton la
vélo route qui passe juste en dessous
c'est un mur qui va se voir même depuis
le la route nationale an à la doua c'est
bon c'est un endroit qui est quand même
visible et les candidats peuvent
toujours se faire connaître les dossiers
sont même téléchargeable sur le site de
l'association des climats du vignoble de
bourgogne